each year the Academy presentations take
on more and more of an international
flavor tonight an added - of Gallic
charm is provided by a Parisian who is
in Hollywood demonstrating that 50
million French women can't be wrong Mr
Al Angelo
I see welcome to Hollywood alone thank
you Bob
I'm delighted to be over here even
though it is now spring in Paris and the
shit's not coin Bruges you should be
right at home summer minor bloom tonight
too it is my privilege to present the
award a special visual effects
denominator the shipments are Mary
Poppins special visual effects by Peter
Allen show you stage life safe and
hammington loosely seven phases of dr.
Lao special visual effect by Jim
Danforth the winner is Peter Ellen Show
for Mary Poppins
I'd like to say thank you very much
it's been exciting thank you on behalf
of waltz the fine animation Department
and especially max Stuart who had a
great deal to do with winning this thank
you very much as sincere effects to the
max is here thanks to the Academy and
all the people that work beyond this
picture especially the people in my
department who worked very hard to make
this thing possible thank